colin powell one of the leading figures
of american military and foreign policy
for nearly two decades has died at the
age of 84. his family confirmed the news
in the past hour saying powell died from
covert 19 complications he was the first
african-american to serve as both
secretary of state and as the country's
top general reaction from our white
house correspondent and expert guests is
coming up first leah harding looks back
on colin powell's life and
career colin powell spent his career
breaking barriers the son of jamaican
immigrants powell spent 35 years in the
u.s army leading combat forces in
vietnam and eventually becoming a
four-star general powell was ronald
reagan's national security advisor in
the 1980s
in 1989 george h.w bush made him the
pentagon's top military officer chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
i will do whatever president the united
states directs us to do
and what the bush administration wanted
the invasion of iraq in january 1991 in
response to its invasion of kuwait
several months before and with
unrelenting overwhelming use of military
force the powell doctrine was born you
have to have a clear understanding of
why they're being committed for what
purpose and it can't just be we're
seeing all this terrible stuff indicates
that the gulf war turned powell into a
hero
many wanted him to run for president but
powell refused
instead he broke the color barrier once
more the first african-american to serve
as secretary of state during george w
bush's presidency
it was a tenure during which powell did
the one thing that ultimately damaged
his reputation arguing for the invasion
of iraq in 2003 before the u.n security
council acts and iraq's behavior show
that sodom hussein and his regime are
concealing their efforts to produce more
weapons of mass destruction
the evidence of powell's case turned out
to be false powell accepted
responsibility for helping to lead the
country into what he later called an
unjustified war deeply regret that the
information some of the information not
all of it some of the information i
presented which was multi-sourced was
wrong
and it is a lot on my record but you
know i there's nothing i can do to
change that blot over time powell's
regret turned into disillusion with the
republican party he endorsed democratic
presidential candidate barack obama in
2008.
his ability to inspire because of the
inclusive nature of his campaign because
he is reaching out all across america
he gave similar reasons for backing
hillary clinton over donald trump in
2016 and did the same for joe biden in
2020 with joe biden in the white house
you will never doubt
that he will stand with our friends
and stand up to our adversaries never
the other way around
after the storming of the u.s capitol on
january 6 2021 by then president trump
supporters powell announced he was
quitting the republican party and he
called on trump to resign
not surprising for a man who had always
believed in duty to country before
politics and had devoted his career to
just that
so our first guest to talk about the
life of colin powell joining us from
culture so it is natasha linstead who is
a u.s foreign policy specialist deputy
dean at the university of essex thank
you for your time natasha i feel with
someone like colin powell
the
easiest or best way to deal with his
life is to go chronologically because
what happened in 2003 his decision over
the war in iraq can overshadow
everything but there is a lot more to
this man isn't there
yes there is i mean besides the fact
that he was the first african-american
secretary of state
he also was a long-time general and had
the highest military position in the
department of defense and he oversaw
over 28 crises including the invasion of
panama and then of course operation
desert storm
the first gulf war in in iraq and he was
one of the most admired political and
military figures in the u.s his approval
rating was at 88 percent and that really
didn't waver much of course he was
affected
by his support for the second iraq war
but overall he was one of these figures
that all americans liked whether they
were democrats or republicans and he had
a very low
uh disapproval rating of only six
percent so this was one person that
everybody could agree upon and that's
why there was so much uh
fervor over this idea that he should run
for president and he would have won
because he just was so popular he was
perceived to be trustworthy and someone
that all americans could relate to okay
that's what i was just about to ask why
why was this man so popular but i feel
you've you've gone into that now was
there always going to be a transition
from the military to politics for
someone like him who had that much
influence and and as you say high
approval
well he was always just one of these
generals that politicians felt that they
could trust
and he was able to communicate very well
and for this reason the politicians you
know wanted to to work with him and so
we saw that he was the one person chosen
by the bush administration to
to speak in front of the u.n because he
was a person that just had credibility
you know there wasn't really any
blemishes on his his record
and because he was so likable
from either party the republicans or the
democrats
he was going to be this type of person
that would transcend the military and
then pursue a career as secretary of
state in diplomacy
2003 i think we need to start bringing
that into the conversation this decision
to
will he remember the famous speech he
gave before the united nations talking
about wmd in iraq unequivocally
and then later retracting it essentially
how much of a
stain if i can put it that way does that
leave on his diplomatic career at least
well it was definitely a stain and he
himself admitted that this was quote
unquote a blot on his record he was
someone that didn't want to involve the
us in unnecessary military action that
was part of the paul doc powell doctrine
and that in any kind of military action
necessitated public support and needed
to ensure that it was in u.s national
interests so at the time he was trying
to advise bush not to go into iraq he
says we know how to go into baghdad but
you're going to need to have some kind
of plan
for nation building and state building
afterwards and that we're not really
prepared for that so he had warned bush
many times about this but his warnings
went unheeded and as a result he was set
up to then defend u.s um
what the us was going to do in iraq in
front of the un and by doing so
he really made the situation quite worse
because he was reading a speech where he
he mentioned zakawi 21 times in this
speech this was someone who
wasn't that well known and then suddenly
became much more well known of
eventually leading to al qaeda in iraq
so the speech did a lot of harm and also
of course the invasion of iraq did a lot
of harm and there was much feeling that
powell who someone we trusted so much
had betrayed many people because all the
information he had given or at least
some of it turned out to not be true
natasha just stay there for me if you
would and keep listening as well because
i've got another guest i want to bring
in and get some thoughts uh this is
lawrence corp joining us foreign uh
former assistant secretary of defense
who worked with colin powell uh also
senior fellow at the center for american
progress on skype from washington dc
thank you for your time mr corbett and
condolences as well i'm sure you could
hear what natasha and i were discussing
there she was raising the point that in
some ways maybe colin powell was almost
set up and became a fall guy the public
fall guy for the invasion of iraq
well
vice president cheney said you're the
only one who has the credibility to make
the case given you know some of the
other statements that the
uh and backgrounds of the other people
in the administration
and i spoke to him after he did it
when i was not no longer in government
nor was he and he said it was a
big mistake but what he was really
trying to do was be a good soldier you
know if you're a soldier
and you get an order as long as it's not
illegal
and you don't agree with it you still
have to carry it out and i think what he
was trying to do he knew they were going
to go he knew that you couldn't make a
definitive case but there was a
reasonable chance that some of this
intelligence might be right and don't
forget
the statement that they wanted him to
give he didn't give i mean he cut it
down he and his uh colleague rich
armitage who i also work with basically
you know took out a lot of the the stuff
that was in there originally so i think
he was trying to compromise and do the
best he could and unfortunately it has
permanently tarnished his reputation as
a statesman but not as a soldier okay
has it i wanted a question did it
permanently tarnish is that the only
thing when when it comes to his
diplomatic career that people think of
because i'm sure he did a lot more than
that and he did
i mean belatedly he made his retraction
as well
yeah not no doubt about it but i mean a
lot of
people did not know that he was a hero
in vietnam for example people forget
that you know what he did there
the fact that
after iran contra he came into the
reagan administration
back from his army career and got things
back on on track i mean people forget
how dangerous that was reagan could have
been impeached if it wasn't so near the
end of his term with the whole iran
contra thing and you know he had worked
in the pentagon went out into the field
as a commander and came back and took
over the national security council and
that has not received the attention that
it should you know what he did there
our previous guest was saying how
popular colin powell was
um maybe you can give us a bit of
personal insight into why that is what
was it about him
which made people like him which gave
him those high approval ratings
uh
as an army general and then into his
early diplomatic career as well
well
first of all he had a wonderful sense of
humor he was always smiling and laughing
and he would see the humorous side even
under some you know very serious type of
things he was very smart and he could
take complex issues and put them in
language that normal people
you know could uh could could understand
he was also a role model because
basically he was an african-american
that was serving in the military in the
southern part of the united states
before
you know the segregation had ended it
was very very difficult for him to be
there you know and he handled that uh
you know so well and then of course
vietnam which was a unwinnable you know
uh war he was able to do that
and you know uh
get his soldiers uh through it so i
think you're right i mean a lot of
people don't know that they only you
know he came on board as secretary of
state and since the whole iraq war was
such a mess he got tarnished by it
lawrence stay there for me if you would
and also natasha who's there i'm going
to come back to both of you but i do
want to check in with our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott now
on the north lawn there kimberly maybe
take us through the actual news of today
how did this news break and what has the
family said
well the family broke this news over
social media noting that not only had
they lost a beloved family member but
also the the the united states had lost
a great american so now we're watching
very carefully for some of the reaction
that has come out uh and the first to
come out in a statement is from the
former president george w bush of course
he served colin powell served in the
bush administration in fact both bush
administrations he says laura and i are
deeply saddened by the death of colin
powell he was a great public servant
starting his time as a soldier during
vietnam many presidents relied on
general powell's counsel and experience
he was national security adviser under
president reagan chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff under my father and
president clinton and secretary of state
during my administration he was such a
favorite of presidents that he earned
the presidential medal of freedom twice
and he was highly respected at home and
abroad that is certainly true and most
important he was a family man and a
friend laura and i send our sincere
condolences as they remember the life of
a great man and i think that that is
what is most notable
about colin powell
is the fact that he was a friend of both
democrats and republicans something that
you certainly don't see of a man of his
stature uh anymore in the united states
kimberly you've worked as a reporter in
washington for many years
how was he regarded by
the media there as you point out that he
sort of had that that balance that uh i
won't quite say foot in both camps but
he was
yes yes that's right he certainly was uh
he was a republican but he was also
loved by democrats and it is notable
that some of his policies would not be
welcomed by democrats today for example
he was not a fan of gays in the military
and actively spoke out against this
saying that this would threaten
u.s national security and military
readiness of course later on a
generation later that is no longer the
view and that policy has changed but
certainly it is notable that even as he
had strong opinions and differences with
some of his political opponents for
example it's well known that he didn't
always get along with bill clinton a
democratic president
what is notable is the fact that overall
he is remembered as a man that could
work with both political parties
certainly he was revered by the media
you asked about that and certainly from
most americans even if they felt that he
uh may have made some mistakes
throughout his career overall they
revere him as a a man who was certainly
a very great public servant and a great
american kimberly halcott is our white
house correspondent thank you for now
with us still uh natasha linstead and uh
lawrence corb to talk through more of
the life of colin powell thank you for
staying with us and for listening to our
other comments natasha let me come back
to you
kimberly made the point about his i
can't call it bipartisanship but he was
he was a republican who democrats could
could deal with
and later on as we heard in our report
he openly supported the likes of of of
joe biden
those type of people don't really exist
anymore do they
right well i think the
the good thing about colin powell was he
always at least from americans
perspective was telling the truth or
what he believed to be the truth and
there's this perception
that politicians don't tell the truth
they say whatever's you know is going to
benefit them in that moment and colin
powell was someone who was really
admirable
for being a straight shooter and for
clearly communicating things and for
just looking at the facts and to not get
caught up in you know messy conflicts
about politics and i think one of the
testament to this is that he actually
apologized about the iraq conflict we
didn't hear an apology from from bush or
from roensfeld or from dick cheney
but he was able to reflect upon it and
say that this was a mistake and i think
that is something that's admiral bottom
that we don't really have from
politicians today
lawrence corbyn washington dc why didn't
he run for president it seems like he
could have done that
possibly on multiple occasions and might
have been pretty close to it
actually he was thinking of running in
1996
uh and his wife alma talked him out of
it she was afraid for his life that as
the first african-american you know to
to get the nomination he you know he
some people might come after him and i
remember you know reading about that in
his book and talking to him about i
think he would have been a great
president i think he would have won if
he had
run in 96 or 2 000 but that's my
understanding and that says a lot about
this country that you know a man or
person of such great stature intellect
and bravery is a you know it doesn't
want to run because of what happens to
be his skin color
lawrence corb former assistant secretary
of defense and natasha
lindstad u.s foreign policy specialist
thank you both for your time and and
your thoughts today
on the life of colin powell